tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul
novantanovesimo episodio di su motori
trims non è su motori a no vabbè allora
grazie a parte gli scherzi stiamo sul 90
90 episodio di happy wheels e sto per
fare un annuncio obama mi stai guardando
che sto per fare l'annuncio importanti
c'è anche obama
ciao barak abbiamo anche c'è anche renzi
c'è anche renzi ci sta guardando tutti
buongiorno signor renzi ci dica in
inglese come si dice annuncio averne
importa che con carezze a parte gli
scherzi l'annuncio che sto per fare che
alcuni già lo sapevano prova bene che
per il centesimo episodio di happy meals
ovvero l'episodio della settimana
prossima primo maggio quindi segnatevi
domenica primo maggio farò al centesimo
episodio di happy meals in live
esattamente alle tre del pomeriggio ci
sarà la live su heavy wheels quindi
domenica primo maggio alle 3 3 di
pomeriggio è ovviamente che mi sveglio
di notte per farle lipid ragazzi spero
sarete in tanti a guardarla apportate
anche la nonna e niente siccome mi sono
tipo dilungato davvero un'ora e mezza il
video è finito ci vediamo in un prossimo
video ma vi fosse un pochettino di
gameplay può anche farlo va bene
stavolta va contento per tutti ragazzini
ottenuto noi ci sono famiglie e sia la
scelta è più un gioco che non ho mai
fatto sono 99 volte chatrier è
tantissimo quatar helmets four a che
cosa servono i caschi lavorano su questo
su questo videogame un cazzo zio
e si capisce che i 99 episodi di happy
sì io non ho ancora capito un cazzo che
vuol fixed sono questi sapere ragazzi
quando giocherò il gameplay in live
cercherò di cercherò di farlo durare un
po di più perché se continua a vincere
così magari durante secondi poi finisce
il video è che posso stato tutto il
video a vincere poi effettivamente la
gente potrebbe annoiarsi se vinco troppo
verdeoro non fermi ma cos'è un
trampolino ma è bellissimo è stupendo
prima ho fatto boss come ho fatto a fare
bossi impossibile cioè lo vince la prima
volta ragazzino lui
[Musica]
ecco un run allora siamo nel 2016 stiamo
andando verso il 2017 è più il se esiste
da quando sono nato io è da quando sono
nato io esistono sti cazzo di livelli ma
nessuno si annoia giocare stia su un run
di merda
vi prego spiegate perchè non ho capito
cos'è successo se quella roba lì
kamasutra non ho capito ragazzi io ve ne
importa
chissà perché ogni volta ogni caso di
episodio deve succedere qualcosa di
strano che non mi so spiegare e sono 99
episodi e questo è grave salto della
vita zia complimenti hai fatto un salto
ramente stupendo dai fai vedere che
tutta quella nutella non è stata
ingurgitate in vana ma vaffan cuore va
beh io ancora non basta ma perché non
c'è una mira oggi ragazzi non è mica che
sanno cos'è successo
lo zio ti viene la radar mio culo però
le mani
era un salvare o finalmente qualcosa che
non c'entra con gli altri anni però ci
sono le frecce che le odio uguale
praticamente anche davide bloc ma devo
scrivere dopo dio non oggi ahia ahia
l'ispezione nel deretano l'ho già fatta
l'altro giorno dal medico grazie va beh
questa è una cosa che non si può mettere
su youtube ragazzi questo è successa la
mia gamba mi fate capire come si fa è
impossibile
come faccio a sopravvivere delle frecce
non mi va per culo cioè il senso mi
vanno nel culo a ciò facendo miracolo
incredibile non è che non sono morto
cosa è successo grazie
non mi sembrava strano ho capito e
allora ti dico sì che cosa vuoi
stai frate da ho finalmente embè
l'arpione nel deretano
[Musica]
e già qualcosa ragazzo la 24 secondi per
fini sta cagate però c'è qualcosa o
ragazzi livello mai fatto purtroppo
perfetto
devo dov'è la vittoria dov'è la vittoria
i ragazzi nella laives
siccome nella live non posso c'è nel
senso non ci sono i tagli
vi darò dimostrazione che io
effettivamente sono un fenomeno contro
gli farò proprio vedere che vinco sempre
tipo adesso che culo stronzo ragazzi da
da quando ho detto sta frase non
riuscirò mai più a vincere un volto non
lo so lo sento a parte questo era
destinati non ne vincerò mai più uno son
convinto a vita jet trapped criticata it
it is possible
te lo dico io cosa è possibile scrivere
possible con due esse sarebbe un inizio
allora zio e fammi capire come è
possibile
devo andare a vabbè mica una cagata
ok c'è dal traguardo anche a sinistra
meno male perché stavo per fare figure
di merda iscritte office facciamo scappa
dall'ufficio tra l'altro ok
ne ho abbastanza di questo lavoro perché
oggi il tuo lavoro e di che cosa c'è di
male è che cosa c'è di male nello
smistare la posta di rocco siffredi
c'è qualcosa di male effettivamente
visto che cadono i pavimenti che fa
angolo fuori
oddio ma sta chiedendo aiuto io sto
spingendo giustamente aspetta che ti
aiuto io stavo scherzando chef the power
esata un destro
devo saltare giù dalla finestra per
quale motivo salve sono un lavoratore
che scappa e sto scappando da tanto
piacere stupido pezzo di merda smistare
le mail di rocco deve essere un lavoro
snervante gli piace sia questo qua è
l'unico gemito che posso mai farti fare
ragazzi ma che lavoro è che tutti si
stanno stancando e non ci hanno voglia
di andare di continuare che robles tra i
top rider e senti zio anche volendo non
mi potresti uccidere perché sono più
basso della tua pistola quindi creato
schiacciavo se adesso questa è
tranquilla non non ci arrivi ci
arriveremo non si potesse abbassare
ragazzi ma mi ha [ __ ] leggermente
come che solo senza gambe come lo perse
reagan corli macori cosa dove dove vuoi
che vada non lo capiscono ma perché c'è
gente con le pistole in chiaro come
quanto emerge oggi io sono cascato
sicurissimo sono arrivato al traguardo
ok no no aspetta cosa è successo ma come
non possano non ci possa arrivare al
traguardo posto davanti a voi ragazzi
uguale libertà una lacrima storia strana
a villa pini mega jump al awsat abel io
le adoro se così di saltare
dite che ho vinto noi ne sono
completamente sicuro ragazza a giudicare
dal suo stato direi forse si fa del sans
cos'è io non sto capendo fermina più
così dopo a causare la pompa perfetto la
bomba serve per uccidere stie liuc che
non ho capito bene la perfetto pensavo
fosse solo questo livello terminati o un
perfetto ragazzi del caffè limbo file in
borsa
[Musica]
guadagno che si sta decomponendo di
sopra ragazzi ma è un livello dove devo
sopravvivere solo cosa sta facendo
ma sei scemo ragazzi perché guidare la
bici in modo normale troppo mainstream
io vado in bici così da che ora da
ragazzi detto questo facciamo un paio di
miei livelli che sarebbero dj lang il
cazzo è accuse ragazzi del bello la
partenza è stata geniale come mai parto
che ogni bilancio in 10 mila pezzi
lasciate un bel mi piace per la parola
di legno regia che insegna termini a
questa era livello complimenti cioè le
sei un visionario prodigio e faccio un
livello incredibile grandissimo in
questo livello dovrai affrontare le
angurie non avresti mai detto vero no
per carità di dio fa vj ce l'ha duro
favilli ce l'ha duro non lo voglio
giocare grazie però per avermi detto fa
vj boltro facciamo boltro decente è vero
iddio non spiega non ho letto cosa c'è
scritto a farvi prova a farlo ti prego e
ti sfido commento che non ce la farà il
primo colpo fedez grazie fedez niente o
questo corpo italiano fighissimo morte
rapida fa vedere che morte rapida
non lo so ali non sapete cosa scrivere
giusto famiglia tedesca prendere morte
rapida
hai fatto male i suoi calcoli frate cosa
va beh allora e impulsivi come faccia
fare sta roba
ma sei sicuro che si possa vincere o
victoria non vorrei solo preso lega
dei ragazzi chiudo qui l'episodio è
strano perché nei livelli editati di è
più visto in genere mette un sacco di
replay un sacco di roba e non so come
verrà la live visto che sarà lunga
almeno almeno un'ora almeno quindi
ragazzi spero che ci sarete tutti il
primo maggio domenica farò anche
l'annuncio su facebook comunque portate
tutti gli amici la nonna al cugino il
fratello per il centesimo episodio di ai
primis che farò in live alle tre del
pomeriggio quindi sintonizzatevi su
boing quindi ragazzi servito è piaciuto
ma sente lasciato sgomento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come
miglior descrizione se non si discute ci
diamo la possibilità ai ragazzi